what do you produce uh mostly music
videos uh but all kinds of content
related stuff um for other people or
just for you just for me so so you just
have a production company for yourself
yeah okay I all my music videos I have a
hand in producing I mean some of the
stuff thank you that's what I need right
there you guys the stuff I shot in
Serbia was in the millions of dollars I
did a three-piece video I lived in for 3
months Serbia so wait you live there for
3 months yeah just to shoot these videos
just to shoot these videos and I also
played there one other time and um I
brought I lost all my clothes because uh
I was traveling from Turkey from a show
there and for whatever reason all our
bags got lost so we had to buy like
these Slavic you know Adidas jumpsuits
and we played the show and um and I
brought this little like horse to throw
out into the crowd and then I threw it
back in the microphone stand hit my
mouth and it actually chipped my tooth
in half my front tooth I had to get it
replaced wow looks good now right let's
see looks good no you can tell something
you can tell something still up with it
yeah there's something in my teeth yeah
it just looks kind of weird off well
anyways Cody's like I love and
uh Serbia is amazing shout out Serbia
and uh I film his videos so there's
bigger scale stuff seran presid in
millions of dollars you know so we do
some stuff I am actually curious like
why did you go there have you ever been
to the Eastern block uh I've been to
Turkey that's not the Eastern block
moving into Asia yeah no I've never been
to so I've spent a fair amount time to
Slovenia that does that count yeah that
was part of that's Slavic yeah that's
pretty far over I've been toia like
three times but anyways so I've spent
time filming music videos in Ukraine in
Russia I lived in Russia for a while as
well um and then why because of the
aesthetic that you get I love the
aesthetic there I love what's going on
there film making specifically Russia
has the craziest film making they like
they're film schools are just at another
level everything is just kind of at a
different caliber I feel like a smaller
artist potentially in Russia might have
a a music video that is like maybe what
better than most the big scale artists
in America it's just aesthetically
different but for me specifically why I
chose Serbia was when I went there I was
just looking around and the buildings
are insane yeah the architecture is
really Next Level and they have this
brutalist style that's these big
concrete pretty like end of the worldes
or futuristic buildings but just the
buildings there speak to me so I I chose
it purely based on that as well as just
yeah it's like I have no place that I
live so my whole year is like okay I
have to go and film these music videos
but it doesn't say where so for me I'm
like all right let's go somewhere that I
want to go so like for my album I chose
to live in Brazil in Rio de Janeiro I
rented this Glass House in the jungle
and I recorded there also spent three
months there so half the year alone was
just spent just in those two places and
then I literally was in la which is
where I like frequent the most out of
anywhere else and I only was here for
like 3 months out of the entire year so
I'm like why would I pay rent why would
I even buy a house um and if you don't
spend time in California you can get off
the California taxes ah so when you are
in so he didn't want to pay taxes on his
production yeah yeah yeah no I didn't
say
that you guys direct your music videos
he
did I like this guy I like this guy
no just holds the yeah yeah me me and
nema's bid is that Nema just gives me
like the leap frog and I he I pretend
I'm directing I like it yeah so you guys
collaborate yeah how much prep do you do
for the directing I don't know what
anytime we've gone to shoot stuff I
actually have like really unrealistic
goals I want to get like a [__] ton of
shots and stuff that we can't afford but
yep that's the case always there's never
enough money and never enough time but
Nea helps me uh make it realistic so do
you direct yours I direct all of them
write them all and I've been producing
all of them the last two albums I
started crediting myself as a producer
cuz I'm like I'm already producing this
and now I'm even cutting out the
producer fee which can be 15 10 anywhere
from 10 to 20% off the back end which is
just money that I'm always looking at my
videos I'm like why do they look so
shitty and it's because people are
taking the money and putting it in their
pockets and literally I'm the Golden
Goose like Oliver we love you so much
man you're such a cool dude can't wait
to make the next one and then they buy
Tesla and a house under the Hollywood
sign and I'm like what the [__] why does
this video look so shitty so much of it
for me is like if I have to be in it I
need to be so I need to understand every
you need to regardless if you're in it
or not but like it's even more important
that I go there and I film all my videos
on a cell phone before and have every
millisecond accounted for like there is
not the great part of the style is I've
created this Henry Ford autoline mass
production of the videos so like the
video is already edited before I even
shoot it because I have the cell phone
version so I have a dit person who just
uploads the footage onto the hard drive
onto the computer
and we literally have them just slide in
all the shots into the edit and we are
marking constantly okay this one's the
this one's the best one or we give them
the the selects do you like as far as
like VFX artists do you have like a set
that like you on set for my Serbia
production I never done it this way
where we had an editor who was editing
he was live editing while we shot it so
it's one thing to be filming it while
you edit it but there's another thing to
have someone who's actually screen
recording the Monitor and putting in the
takes so that we could see continuity as
was happening so if something cuz if you
already have moved to the next shot it's
too late you already even if someone's
on set editing it it's really too late
so for continuity purposes for the
bigger scale stuff we had someone
actually editing live and then there was
my friend Z who was doing live VFX with
AI putting mockups together on set so we
actually were doing live VFX and live
editing and like truly live like as we
would do the take we could have it flown
in and immediately see it so it
streamlined so crazy fast and when I was
filming in London this year there was a
shoot I did and someone taught me he's
like there's three things that film sets
have and one of them is you either have
money uh you either have time or you
either have skills and you never have
three basically no matter what you're
only going so if you don't have skills
you need more money well this is for you
guys if you don't have skills then you
need more time and you need more money
which you know if you need more time
then you need more money and if you
don't have the money then you're going
to need to have the skills and you're
going to need more time to do it so this
whole kind of thing where the equation
is you're screwed always yeah and that's
my life h h
h you're like DJing now right I want a
DJ that's what I want he wants to be a
DJ that's my true passion and how is the
DJ path it's good I used to be a DJ do
you know this I think you told me this
in my place yeah all right let's try it
again just say
no all right go again so I used to be a
DJ do you know this no tell me more
more oh let's go again one more time
yeah all right didn't you used to be a
DJ dude let me do the okay got it got it
got it go
ahead who's in the scene we're all
talking at the same time this will never
work all right we'll have to start over
just cut got it go ahead C try again
we're rolling yeah yeah which cam he
actually cut all right all right so I
used to be a DJ do you know this
dude
what that works that was actually really
good it wasn't the exact response I was
looking for
what okay it's okay I used to but guess
what you don't have to be sad oh what
I'm returning and maybe one day you can
open up for my DJ
set I would honestly I would we'll talk
see I'm still in the learning phase so
show you I'm still I used to do these
crazy moves which I could teach you I
would do matchups Right double setup hot
qes six three on each Pioneer and then I
would Loop a different song In The
Middle on the mixer and I would have
that looping and then I would do this D
and create actually a riser live with
the pitch and then I would be able to
hit both of them but both would be hit
at the same time and there wasn't an
extra third hand so what did I do one
two three use your penis no that would
be good a that would be sick yeah you
can you should do that I'm not I'm not a
DJ so I couldn't visualize what you guys
were talking about I have no idea what I
no idea what the [__] you're talking
about oh yeah okay all
right yeah on your podcast yeah that's
enough chitat yeah when you said I use
my use my that's
enough you remember that sound from Vine
it's working now remember that one hit
it again take him back wait wait
announce the DJ thing again all right
ladies and
gentlemen I am putting together the
greatest DJ show of all time one that
will change the face of DJing
audiovisual
experiences did you cue the sound
already hold on I played the wrong one
are you trying to [__] with me sorry
announce it again the greatest show ever
made Dr Oliver tree dubstep
DJ I don't think that we should use that
no we'll keep
it